Taylor Swift has been named The Time
Magazine person of the year some
Liberals are upset by this because a
basically normal white lady won the
award some conservatives are upset by
this because a vaguely liberal lady won
the award and to all of them I quote
Chris Christie this is a smart
accomplished woman you should stop
insulting us listen here I have a decent
amount of credibility on this issue
because I was the 2006 Time person of
the year Myself and I say she totally
deserves it or she almost totally
deserves it and Taylor Swift is
genuinely a phenomenon she is not a scop
people actually really like her I don't
really get it because I'm neither a
millennial woman nor a homosexual but I
am convinced that her popularity is not
contrived but of all the people that
time could have picked Taylor Swift is
easily one of the best she's cleancut
she's pretty and best and most shocking
of all she's normal